Hello, everyone.
My name is David Maguire.
I am a data
scientist at dv01.
We are a fintech startup
and we provide analytics
for investors in fixed income.
So something that I've heard
a few times over my career
is that R is bad for production.
Sometimes engineers say,
oh, this looks great.
But let's put it in another
language for production.
They say R is ad hoc.
It's for analysis.
There's no package management.
But today, I want to dispel
some of those notions
and I want to show you that
R is great for production.
So first I'd like
to talk a little bit
about what I work on.
So I work on Tape Cracker,
which is a web application that
has a few components.
There's a JavaScript front
end, there's a Scala backend,
and then we have a machine
learning microservice
in R, which provides
predictions that
are used by the two other
components of the application.
And this application is
used live by customers.
They can get on at any time.
They expect their
results immediately.
So there's, there's very high
requirements for availability
and dependability.
Our sales team demos
this app live to clients
to prospective clients.
So it has to work every time.
If there is a failure we could
lose a prospective client.
So this machine
learning microservice
has to be very
robustly engineered
to satisfy what our
customers expect of us.
So I'm going to tell you, how
can you raise an R microservice
to thrive in the wild?
So here we have
our R microservice.
This cute little giraffe.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to put our R
microservice through school.
We're going to teach it what
to do once we release it out
into the wild.
The end result of that is
that once we release it
into the wild, it can interact
with other microservices,
other applications written in
different languages seamlessly
and just have a fun time.
So let's talk a little
bit more concretely.
What is an R microservice?
So it's basically R code
behind plumber and Docker.
So we take our R code, our
machine learning model
and we put it behind
a plumber API.
This allows any
other application
to hit our machine
learning model
and it only has to provide
the expected inputs
and it gets an output.
So any other service doesn't
need to know anything
about the R language.
And then we wrap around
that plumber API.
We put it in a Docker package.
This makes our API portable.
So once it's in a Docker
package or a Docker image,
we can deploy it into the cloud
on a variety of destinations.
So a little bit more concretely
in our circumstance at dv01,
the microservice while we
this is our web application.
This is what it looks like.
It provides a lot of
information that investors
need to make decisions.
And we have a JavaScript front
end, we have a Scala backend,
and then behind that even we
have a machine data engineering
pipeline in Scala and
we have our R machine
learning microservice
sits on top of that.
And is able to provide
results to each
of the components
in that pipeline.
So this is a great setup
for a data scientist
because I can focus on
what I'm good at, which
is building models and
building data science projects.
And then the software
engineers that I
work with, they can build
the end to end system.
So very convenient.
So in pursuit of building
robust R deployments,
I want to introduce
three DevOps principles.
The first is
continuous integration,
and that's where we build
and test our R packages.
The second is
continuous deployment.
This is where we take
our tested packages
and release them into
production systems.
And then the third is
cluster computing,
which is a common destination
for applications
in production in the cloud.
So let's start with
continuous integration.
This is a simple continuous
integration workflow.
So we start at the top
left where a data scientist
is working in R in RStudio,
making updates to the model,
making updates to the code.
So whenever a data scientist
makes an update the code base,
they will push that to a version
tracking tool such as GitHub.
At that point, the
application will
be built from the source code.
And then we're going to run
automated tests on that.
And this happens automatically.
Once I push all that
happens and then
I'll get a report
back. If the test fail,
I know I have to go
back and fix something.
If they test pass,
I can then progress.
I can merge my changes
into the master branch
and then we will
have an application
that is ready for deployment.
So let's look a
little bit closer
into this first part
of the CI pipeline.
So this in the CI build step.
Basically, we have a data
scientist is working in RStudio
writing R code and we
are going to Git push
and that's going to trigger
GitHub Actions to kick off
the continuous
integration pipeline.
There's many options
for CI tools.
We use GitHub
Actions at dv01,
and then the GitHub Actions is
going to build a Docker image
based on the updated code.
And what's important
here is that I
am pushing my code frequently.
That means that I can get
instant feedback on what
each piece of code
that I edit and so I
know where changes happen.
If I push 500 lines of code
at once and something fails,
it's going to take
me a long time
to figure out what goes wrong.
But if I push a couple
lines at a time,
I can isolate the
problems very easily.
So now let's look
at this next step.
We're running the
automated tests.
So within continuous
integration tests,
we have three broad categories
of tests, sort of there's
this pyramid structure,
the base are unit tests.
These are the most numerous
tests that we have.
Above those,
we have integration
tests which are still
a good amount of those,
but less than unit tests.
And finally, there are end
to end tests. And the
testthat package is very useful
for writing these type of tests.
So starting at unit
tests, this is the base
of our testing pyramid.
And the goal here is
to test functions,
individual lines
of code and really
look at each component
of your R package.
So here I have a trivial
example of a unit test
where I, I define
this add 20 function
and then I use testthat to
assert that if I add 20 to 10,
it should equal 30.
And I define this
and this is going
to run every time I push
updates to my package.
So if I were to make any
changes to this function that
would break it, I would
get immediate feedback.
And these type of tests are
something that you should
have a lot of. For example,
it's a really good idea
to create unit tests
for your features, to make
sure that all the features that
go into your models have
tests and/or never break
or never give unexpected input.
If you're imputing missing
values at prediction time,
that would be a good
thing to unit test.
You can also test
like data structures,
make sure that
functions return data
frames of expected structures
and things like that.
So writing a lot
of these unit tests
allows you to make sure
that your code doesn't
break in unexpected ways and
it helps you identify failures.
So the next level
is integration tests.
So for integration
tests, the goal
is to make sure that
our R microservice can
interact with other services
that it will need to.
So we may be interacting
with databases or APIs.
So we're going to write
tests and make sure
that our R container can interact
with every service it needs.
And finally, there
are end to end tests,
and this is where we're looking
at the whole microservices
application as a whole.
So this is in our case, is
looking at our whole web app.
It doesn't really tell us
much about our R microservice,
but it's necessary to have a
holistic view of everything.
Where we actually get useful
input about our R package
are the two previous
categories of tests.
Now when we're writing
tests, we want to write them
at the right time.
If you start writing
tests too early,
you can waste a lot
of time, but they save
a lot of time in production.
So if you start a
new project when
you're in the exploratory phase
doing EDA, initial experiments,
if you start writing
a lot of tests,
you're going to
slow yourself down.
But as you progress, as you get
your feature set more concrete,
as you get closer
to production, you
should start introducing
first unit tests, later
integration tests.
And once you're really
close to production
to releasing a
microservice, you're
going to want to make sure
that the end to end tests
are properly configured and.
So next we're going to talk
about continuous deployment.
So at the end of the continuous
integration pipeline,
we have our container
that's ready for deployment.
And what is going
to happen here is
that this pipeline is going
to take that container,
and it's going to
push it through
our different environment.
Here at dv01e, we have a
staging release and production
environment.
There's many ways to do
continuous deployment,
but this is just one example.
So once the container
is ready, it's
going to be pushed to staging.
And in staging there will be
some end to end tests that run
and we'll just make sure that
the whole application looks
good as a whole, that
if that goes well,
it moves on to release.
And then finally it'll
go to production.
And this is important because
we have a customer
facing application
and we have zero tolerance for
any failures or for downtime.
So we really need
to make sure that we
have a lot of steps
in place to catch
any errors that might come up.
And each of these
environments, the staging,
the release ,and production
is a full replica
of the production environment.
It has our web application
as our R microservice,
as well as all
the other services
that make up the application.
So let's talk a little bit
about the last concept, which
is cluster computing.
So in the cloud, a common way
to run jobs is in Kubernetes.
So here we have our
production cluster
in which we have three replicas
of our machine learning
application.
So it's important that we
don't just we're not just
running it once.
We're running it several
times that we have redundant.
So when another microservice
comes along and says,
hey R, give me
some predictions.
It's going to first
go to load balancer.
The load balancer
is going to look
at all the replicas of our R
machine learning microservice,
and it's going to route
it to one that is free
and that is error free.
And then the R microservice
will respond back.
And then the default
microservice application
can continue doing its work.
And so what's important
here is I mentioned
this is a ReplicaSet.
So in kubernetes,
you have ReplicaSet,
which basically says that
for this application,
you're going to
have always going
to have three instances of
this application in this case.
And if one of if one of
the replicas goes bad,
it will be torn
down and a new one
will be spun up immediately.
If we're getting
high traffic, we
can route new traffic to a free
replica of our microservice.
So it's very important.
It gives us redundancy
and it allows us
to handle high request loads.
This also allows scaling.
So in conclusion,
I just want to show
that R is great for production
with proper Ci and CD
practices.
Continuous integration of you
build and vet your R packages,
continuous deployment help
you release updates seamlessly.
Plumber
is an important component
for a microservice
because it packages your
R code behind an API
where any service that
has no knowledge of R
can get results
from your R code.
And then Docker creates these
portable software packages
that you can run on your laptop,
you can run in the cloud.
And then Kubernetes
is essentially
a orchestration,
orchestration engine
that will take those Docker
your Dockerized application
and run it in the cloud.
It helps you
maintain redundancy.
It has helped that helps
make sure that your application
doesn't.
And Thank you.
And if anyone has
some questions,
I'll be happy to take them.